I want to change course now we're not
talking about Cox bird fighting anymore
we want to get into why Robert's running
for the presidency oh don't you don't
you want to do that before he goes don't
you think we should do it you know I
mean and already can I just say this
yeah sir can I call you sir
can I do this sir yes yeah I don't know
I've never seen it I've never met
anybody that's wrong
are you swimming I got about what is
that I'm doing so bad now sir
for Toby yeah
I expect a position I'll do whatever
wait that's a good question I'll be a
janitor yeah like don't you want to be
appointed
um what would Bobby be appointed how
about ambassadors some sort of Island
yeah the Philippines
[Laughter]
when did you decide to run
um about I don't know we decided
together by the way because
um but it I
I had the idea first
yeah I have a favor honey
let me hear it why I need to hear them
first before I say yes late at night
you're laying in bed and you just kind
of said it no what happened it was
because I was being censored
and then I and I was being very very
heavily censored on the social media and
and um and uh and then when the war
started when the Ukraine war I was uh I
was very critical of that and those that
stuff was being censored too
and I uh I just I I felt like I you know
I saw that
the Democratic party my party had
abandoned some of its uh key
um uh principles you know including uh
you know it's alliance with the with the
middle class with a Working Poor in our
country that it was it was becoming
increasingly light with Wall Street and
with a war machine
and the censorship industrial complex
and so I thought well one of the ways
that I could uh that I could talk to the
American public for the first time is if
I run because there's rules that make it
much more difficult for people to censor
you if you were running for president
but I also know that it would not be
fair to my family
and it would not get by my wife if I if
I was just running because you know to
push a principal or and but then a guy
called uh Jeremy's hogby who runs one of
the biggest polling firms in our country
well I didn't know but he was polling me
without me knowing it wow so he was
putting me in a lot of his polls and the
numbers that were coming back despite
the kind of constant attacks on me
the numbers show that I had the highest
popularity rating of any uh political
leader in the country
and so I showed he he sent me an email
saying I need to show you these polling
results and then he came over and showed
them to Cheryl and me
and at that point
um she started thinking well if there's
really a path to victory that
um that she might you know buy into it
and that we had that discussion for
several months
before finally
um she green lighted it it's so funny
because what happens we know even as
podcasters and as a comedian as an actor
I'm online a lot and what happens online
the things that you hear say and all the
stuff that you it's not really reality
no when you go out and when you go out
in the world that's reality that's true
yeah I mean so I think that's what I
think yeah um that's a scary part too
though whatever you say you could talk
for three hours and it can be reduced
they'll take out two words yeah and then
that's what that's what they'll go with
yeah not not even what the conversation
I mean I they you know I'm I was just
called dismissed as any facts I've never
been any vaccine yeah but that was the
um that was a label that was put on me
in order to censor made it silence it
discredited me
I'm not complaining I don't want it to
sound like that but that's what was
happening and
um you know for me I think it's better
to have a dialogue yeah and to be you
know have respectful congenial debate
with people
which was the kind of democracy that I
grew up with yeah yeah so when Bobby was
talking about uh you know right now the
country is so divided right there's so
many people we hate each other we've
been pitted against each other for so
long so when he started talking about
um a place in the Middle where can't we
bring two sides together